protect your bubble calm proud sponsors
of swipe on Sky News you're watching
swipe on the show this week helmets with
brake lights and radar on the roads the
tech hoping to make cycling safer I take
a look at the thermal imaging being used
to detect riders in the capital and as
always our pick of this week's games
releases hello welcome to swipe this
week we're taking on the streets of
London two wheels cycling is more
popular than ever before but it's
getting harder to stay safe but don't be
disheartened Will's been taking a look
at the technology being used to make
cycling less dangerous
cycling is a healthy thing to do but it
can also be dangerous
over the last decade around 25,000
riders have been killed across Europe
but new technology could help to make
roads safer the bike helmet already does
a good job of protecting us but one
inventor thinks he's improved it by
using a wireless remote
Lumos signals the direction you want to
turn and flashes when you want to stop
before you make the turn you press the
right button that wirelessly activates
the right turn signal on your helmets
beep goes up the beeper on a helmet goes
off so that you know that it that it's
working you give your hand signals as
you normally would you make the turn you
complete the turn you press the button
again the light goes off another helmet
innovation is this an airbag for your
head uses sensors in a collar to track
movement and inflates if you have an
accident not all safety tech relies on
sensors Volvo's come up with a
reflective spray to help riders stand
out and these handlebar grips are fitted
with LEDs so vehicles are less likely to
turn into them but will any of this make
a difference there is actually quite a
danger that people rely on these these
gimmicks these technologies thinking
that they have better protective effect
than they do they might have a small
effect but if people think are unsafe
I'm covered in fancy paint or bright
lights and the evidence is that that
makes very little difference then they
are less likely to take as much hair as
they need to radars also being used to
improve safety this gadget from Garmin
sits on the back of your bike and warns
you if vehicles are approaching and
Transport for London are trolling radar
sensors to detect cyclists that's not
all we look into the future seeing what
opportunities there are to get better
data as to how people are using the
existing transport systems and road
network how people are using London as a
place
looking towards what the industry can
provide in terms of sort of spatial data
positional data some of that might
involve mobile phone technology GPS
another project being worked on by TfL
involves thermal technology so we sent
Gemma out on her bike to find out how it
works so this is a cycle superhighway
three yep and we're about to get caught
on some very special cameras that's what
we've done the first time ever is
installed some thermal imaging cameras
up here to detect cyclists so it can use
those to change the traffic signal
timers to help them out well they're
just up here so if we have a look at the
top of this traffic signal poles at the
top while up there we've got two black
tennis ball looking detectors and there
are thermal cameras so how useful is
that it's really useful because the
first time ever we can actually work out
how much cyclists are coming through a
junction so it can help them out and get
them moving on their way so does that
mean that the busier this area
the longer the motorists are going to
wait this will have a green light yeah
what we're doing is trying to balance
the needs of everyone so the cyclists
the vehicle drivers people in the buses
and the people in taxis and how will you
know when the trials be successful so
we're just concluding our second stage
of trials right now by the end of the
year we should know just how effective
these cameras really are you're watching
right up next this week's gaming delight
but first here's a bite-sized chunk of
other tech news for the past few days
professor Stephen Hawking launched a 100
million dollar hunt for aliens this week
it'll be the most comprehensive search
ever for alien life with scientists
scanning a million of our nearest stars
over the next decade listening for
potential radio signals the project is
being funded by tech billionaire Yuri
Milner there's no question it's time to
commit to finding the answer to search
for life beyond Earth we are live we are
intelligent we must know cameras are
being embedded into rhinos horns in
South Africa so that Rangers can catch
poachers in the act the British team
behind the projects are also using
heartrate monitors that are triggered
during an attack a GPS tracker then
tells Rangers where the animal is and
they can head to the scene looks like
the selfie stick just got an upgrade on
crowdfunding site IndieGoGo using the
solo cam you can present your own shows
without the need for a camera crew with
an attached microphone and joystick
control away you go Mojo's that's mobile
journalists to you and me now it's time
for a look at the latest videogames
releases here's Luke Kamali
Colet site 2 is a shooter but it's a
shooter unlike anyone you've probably
played before so the first thing and the
most important point is that it's
completely free you don't have to pay
anything and you can download it right
now on your ps4 and basically the scale
of it is the thing to take into account
actually hold the Guinness world record
for the biggest Firefly ever taken place
in a virtual game over a thousand people
completing in one firefight and the idea
is when you first start use one of three
factions and you basically represent
them and you can choose with six classes
you are fighting for control of for
massive continent in this huge open
world the key is all about team play so
you want to be moving around with your
teammates because if you go it alone as
a lone wolf it may be tempting but
shockingly one person against a massive
massive army isn't gonna do - well it's
a great game it's very different to
anything people have played before and
as I say it's free to play so all ps4
owners should definitely check that one
f1 2015 is the sixth licensed
installment in the f1 franchise from
codemasters who are known for producing
great racing games unfortunately this
time around with f1 2015 none of that
there there's only two game modes and
the only real difference is a bit of
difficulty which isn't too exciting and
it only focuses on the 2014-2015 season
the sad thing is usually I'd be able to
say if your massive massive f1 fan you
should definitely pick this up because
there's something for you
but unfortunately there's a lot of good
races out there from driveclub to
project cars and even for turf so if you
are a big racing fan really should be
spending your money on those and this
time around give f1 2015 and this game
of thrones episode 5 is the penultimate
chapter in Telltale's story and it
follows house Forrester as they continue
to try and survive in Westeros so the
way it works for those who don't know is
this story kind of weaves in and out of
the narrative that we see in the books
and the shows so you're interacting with
characters like Cersei Tyrion Daenerys
which is all very exciting very good
usually we used to see in the
penultimate episode in the show and even
in Telltale's other series like The
Walking Dead being full of excitement
lots of good stuff happening this time
around it kind of feels like they miss
an opportunity the choices they set up
don't really seem to have much of an
impact that pacings a bit odd
and for some reason tell tales writers
just can't nail Daenerys they very much
seem to be writing a character there's a
lot more devious and ruthless than she
ever is emissions so that doesn't really
work however there are some good points
there scenes with Cersei and Tyrion are
exquisite and their finale is really
really looks to be a big one considering
the choice that you make at the end of
this episode is pretty pretty big
that's it for their suite don't forget
to take a look at Sinese on iPad and
mobile for some bonus features from this
week's episode you get next time bye-bye
protect your bubble comm proud sponsors
of swipe on Sky News